yeah thanks to the organizers opening up
a great workshop and for everyone for
sticking around for the last talk of a
very long week so yeah so I'll be
talking about the quantum hardness of
learning but this is let's say not
particularly from a machine learning
perspective but a computational learning
theory perspective so we are going to be
talking about a very rigorous model and
then prove some lower bounds on what you
can or cannot do so let's see I hope
okay so what is the big idea so in 2005
Scott Aaronson had one of the ten semi
Grand Challenges for quantum computing
where he asked if shallow classical
circuits can actually be learned quantum
efficiently in you know the pack
learning model so the probably
approximately correct model of learning
and the one thing that we show is
unfortunately you can't quantum
resources are not going to give us any
exponential improvement in this model
and this may seem like a contrived
problem or something very theoretical
but why should it even be interesting so
there is a connection to let's say in
your networks because a particular class
of shallow classical circuits can
actually be characterized feed-forward
neural networks so somehow we're talking
about how efficiently you can learn the
weights of these neural networks in this
case of course the one caveat is that
this is a conditional result we don't
have an unconditional result to say that
it's hard so you know if that condition
gets broken but I'll talk about that a
little bit more later on
and finally what we're showing is a
worst-case hardness result so it's not
necessary that you know the whole game
is over there could be something you
could still do on average and for some
interesting subclass of you know maybe
these feed-forward neural networks or
something okay so the nice thing is I
think this is all kind of encapsulate
its different aspects of what's been
happening over the whole week here so
the first thing I guess it is that there
is some connection to learning theory
and machine learning ideas on a
theoretical perspective and that is
basically the idea that we are going to
need
I also need some ideas from circuit
complexity and Robin was very helpful in
introducing some of those concepts so it
will hopefully not seem too foreign to
everyone here and the last part that I
need is actually some results from post
quantum cryptography
so you know if any crypt analysts are
sitting here so we're going to connect
all of these together to kind of prove
our hardness result and so let's kind of
get into it I'll basically introduce
what concepts you need from each of
these aspects and go forward from there
so for the quorum learning theory aspect
what we need to define is a specific
model that we care about so it's usually
called the active learning model so I
have let's say an active learner for a
specific concept class so we're talking
about classical concepts here so it's
just a boolean function from n bits to
one bit and let's say I have a loner a
for that if I have access to the concept
under an Oracle definition so the Oracle
OC kind of hides of particular concepts
C bar and I have to learn it under a
specific distribution D which means that
essentially if I ask for give me a
sample from this distribution x1 and x2
will be distributed according to D and
it'll I'll get the value of you know C
bar of x1 and C bar of x2 when I ask for
it
I'm also given a little more power I'll
say that there is a very specific y1 for
which I want to know the value and the
orchid will tell me what that is and
this is called making a membership query
to the concept because you're checking
depending on whether the value of C bar
of Y is 0 or 1 it tells you the
membership in this concept after doing
this a the learner is going to output
hypotheses and we say that it has to
satisfy certain conditions it should be
it's called that being epsilon
approximate or like a very pretty good
hypothesis if for any random challenge
that is distributed according to this
this distribution D the the fact that
the hypotheses will not match my concept
is very small so think of epsilon is
being won over poly in the number of
bits
so we say that this learner is an
epsilon learner for the concept under
this distribution if for every concept
see in the concept class it'll output a
hypothesis that's epsilon approximate
with high probability which means over
all possible concepts you need to do
pretty well so this is slightly a
special case of what the PAC learning
model so the PAC learning model you need
to satisfy that a is an epsilon learner
for the concept class under every
distribution D so this is a slight
restriction of it but then you know we
want to prove hardness so we want to do
it in a slightly weaker model what do we
care about of course we care about the
running time of the learner we also care
about similarly like how many times
you're going to access the Oracle so
like the sample and time complexity
usually that's what people want a good
question to ask is okay in this case so
all I talked about right now was just a
classical thing so where does the
quantum come into the picture so let's
say we try to make all of the examples
and all of the Oracle access quantized
so a quantum example essentially would
just be a superposition where all the
X's are kind of with amplitude squared
or D of X so why is this a good thing if
you measure this sample essentially you
would get the sample and X according to
the distribution D that's a fairly
standard generalization you can care
about and if you send in a quantum query
you get back with a standard query
access so that's going to be a
membership craze that you make you can
of course ask for things in
superposition and so on so under this
model you can ask like what's a good
choice for D let's do the one thing we
know how to do let's say D is the
uniform distribution on all inputs and
that has worked well in the past because
we know of efficient quantum Learners
under this uniform distribution whether
it's the person who's running algorithm
or work by shooting in Jackson for depth
two circuits and they could do it
essentially by using for your sampling
so all of these techniques somehow you
get a constant number of samples and
then you just for your sample and
analyze it so in more
cases that has worked didn't in most of
the efficient learning algorithms we
have four classes of functions in this
kind of a model usually for your sample
is always hiding in there in one form or
another okay so so much for the learning
model so where are the boolean circuits
away quick refresher so we have the and
or a not gifts that were already defined
previously but there's another kind of
gate that we were born the majority gate
so we say that the majority gate outputs
a 1 if and only if half of the inputs
that go into it is at least one okay
so then any boolean function that goes
from n bits to one bit is said to be
computed by a shallow or constant depth
circuit if the following hood we saw MC
0 and AC 0 previously so NC 0 again you
have only fan into depth circuits and
they're constant depth and polynomial
fan and probably not but probably should
say unbounded finance oh sorry about
that so f will belong to AC 0 if it's
got unbounded fan in and and and or
gates and not gates in there but we also
need another class so we're going to go
one step further from the previous talk
so we're going to have this class called
TC 0 which is also called for threshold
circuits but here you can have majority
gets thrown in so in some sense think of
majority as telling you the threshold of
whether it's at least half or not so any
kind of a threshold circuit can kind of
be broken down as long as you have the
majority circuit so these are the three
classes that we care about there
successively contained in each other and
then the question that we are asking
essentially says can we learn these
concept classes TC 0 AC 0 or MZ 0
efficiently ok so of course one reason
to care about neural net shallow
circuits is because you have these
neural networks that can be modeled so
in this way so here there's no feedback
or anything they just go in one
direction from the input layer to the
output layer and all of these
essentially can be characterized as
threshold circuits
yes it's yeah maybe there is some ideal
way so if you had some way of getting a
signal for this function from let's say
naturally and you had those samples
maybe you can use it to kind of
approximate the widths of a neural
network that you want to model this
concept in some sense okay I'm just
saying that it's probably for a fixed
distribution of learning against all
possible distributions right yeah so so
the uniform rattling is doing it under a
sort of fixed distribution of inputs
right yeah pack learning would do it
against everything so yeah so if you
already know that there are separations
between NC 0 and AC 0 and these
separations have been proved in also
various models like distributed
computing and that some interaction
thrown in and so on so we know that
shallow quantum circuits do something
well so quantum resources in a learning
setting can they can they be you know
harness in an efficient way for us to
show something non-trivial what we know
is in the classical setting these
castles are known to be hard to learn so
that's under assuming that factoring is
hard so this was a result shown by
Colonel in 1993 so of course the
question is well can you factoring is
it's not hard quantumly so definitely
that result doesn't hold so maybe can we
get an improvement and of course as I
said before for some smaller classes
like NC 0 and for depth 2 AC 0 circuits
we do have efficient learners under the
uniform distribution so it's a question
of asking how much can we increase the
power or increase the size of what you
can learn efficiently last part is now
pseudo-random functions so that's what
we need from the post quantum crypto
world so for those not familiar with it
we say that a function family so you
have a collection of function a keyed
function so s is kind of thought of to
be the key that Keys each or indexes
each function in the family and the
function goes from let's say K bits to L
bits and we call this function family
pseudo-random if the following holds
there is no efficient algorithm in this
case what's called a distinguisher which
has access to this function as a black
box and cannot distinguish whether this
function actually comes from my family f
or it's a uniformly random function
going from k bits to l bits and of
course you want to do this with high
probability right so the probability
that i output a 1 when the function is
from my my function family vs. then the
function is randomly output the
difference the buyer should be high so a
natural thing is you want these objects
to be quantized so you can have a
quantum algorithm that has access to
this function family and you will call
that it's quantum secure if we even
given this quantum access to the
function you cannot essentially
distinguish whether f is uniformly
random or not so we take one candidate
PRF and construct it so the candidate
PRF that we care was introduced by
Banerjee PI Karan Rosen in 2012 so it's
constructed using a problem called
learning with rounding and this is kind
of a deterministic variant of learning
with error so you're not sampling noise
again and again and we needed over rings
because we need a very efficient
implementation of it so that we can
actually fit it into constant app
circuits the good thing is we know that
ring LWR under certain conditions
reduces like it's at least as hard as
ring lwe and for the kind of parameters
we're looking at the best known
algorithms that we have require
exponential time so that's a plus point
for us either we have all of these
ingredients let's see how to connect
everything together
so what we want to do is now that I'm
given this PRF family let's say
how do I so I have the concept class
that's given what essentially do I need
to do I need to show that if I had an
efficient learning algorithm for this
problem then I would be able to
construct an efficient distinguisher
that can basically distinguish my pseudo
random family right so how does it go by
doing that well my learner has to make
queries to the concept class but any
distinguisher that I construct has
access to the concept class so somehow
any query that the learner makes my
distinguisher will give the answers
required for it right so if I make if I
ask for a sample it's going to access
the unknown function and then give the
required sample and anytime I ask for a
specific query it's going to do the same
thing at the end of the day the learner
is going to give me a hypothesis and
this is actually a classical hypothesis
that we care about and we'll say that
the distinguisher is going to output a 1
if and only if my learner outputs the
hypothesis evaluates to a 1 and what we
show using quantum information theoretic
arguments is that if my learner outputs
a pretty good approximation of this
unknown concept so 1/2 plus meter
approximation then basically what my
distinguished I can do is actually can
identify my fake random function with
1/2 plus beta over 2 probability so
somehow now you've constructed a
distinguisher that can basically tell
you what's happening because you can
essentially learn the function that's
being hidden so essentially if beta is
at least 1 over Polly of n then your
game is over but of course it matters
that you have to choose a pseudo-random
function that's actually you know
quantum secure for instance factoring
does not work anymore and the last step
actually has to do with showing that
these PRF the instances that we care
about can be computed in TC 0 or AC 0 so
for the first step that means we have to
literally go into the ring' arithmetic
and so on and figure out exactly what
kind of circuits are constructed you
need to sort of play with the parameters
to make it fit into the right size of
circuit but once you can do all of that
and put it together what you essentially
show is that if we think of Ring lwe as
being super hard for quantum computers
then we have shown the existence of some
concept classes that cannot be learned
efficiently in this model of computing
that's basically how the proof goes well
at the end of the day all of this just
seems like a lot of things that are
going on and you just say ok just tell
me what's the main idea this summarizes
all of our results so there - the second
result is something that on the last
line is something I didn't talk about
but that also works for the pad model
the crypto primitives that we use there
respond [ __ ] Shin system which is based
on lwe and I think the idea there is
that somehow the the decryption function
in that case can be computed in a t c0
circuit of depth 2 so if we try to use
the same techniques and make it all go
through then even in a distribution free
pack model so basically for under any
distribution of inputs that you get you
can sort of be kind of anything to learn
it
assuming that LWE cannot be solved in
bgp but the first result that you have
says that essentially if ring LW cannot
be solved in polynomial time then you
have something for t c0 where you can't
have a polynomial time learner the
second one is interesting because this
kind of a result is actually not known
in the classical setting somehow the way
the parameters play around with in the
classical proof if you try to have a
distinguisher that runs in you know
super polynomial time classically then
you don't get a learner that
distinguishes very well for factoring so
you somehow can't get these parameters
to work in the classical setting so
somewhere you need the quantum proof to
make it go through and you also get a
super polynomial time lower bound which
says that for some constant there is no
end to the o of log new to the N
algorithm for a c0 this sort of matches
the upper bound that is
on classically for solving a cz ro
circuits by lineaments or Renaissance so
we're sort of getting tight bound yeah
so of course we had some crypt analysts
sitting here earlier this week what if
they actually managed to solve and break
lwe there are some other candidates that
we can look for except that they are not
computable in very short constant depth
circuits so we can still get some
hardness results for logarithmic depth
circuits but yeah not for constant depth
anymore so if anyone wants to come up
with other primitives that can be
computed in constant depth you know
they're all for that what are some open
questions some specific things that are
of interest is that we know that const
stewey c0 circuits can be solved
efficiently these are just and/or cheese
but classically we know that depth 5 AC
zero circuits cannot be solved
efficiently accordingly we don't know
exactly what is the depth at which it
starts getting hard we just know that
there is some constant for which it's
hard so you know if someone wants to dig
in and figure that out that that is an
interesting thing to understand again
you whether there are there are some
techniques that you can use for for
let's say a subclass of these
feed-forward networks because we show
that some cases it doesn't work but that
doesn't necessarily have to hold for
everything and I guess the next thing is
what can you talk about the learnability
of quantum circuits or States I guess
there are some things known about the
sample efficiency of these things where
it's known just recent results piling
and shown in Chun illan in 2018 where
they talked about requiring only a
polynomial number of samples to
efficiently learn polynomial size
circuits but then yeah whether you can
do it time efficiently is still a
question that's interesting and yeah
what can you do for things like Q and z0
which show exponential advantage
the things change so yeah with that I
will conclude thanks for your attention
and thanks for sticking around so it
seems it was important that the
distribution D was uniform sufficient in
order for the reduction to go through
from sort of learning to yes yes that is
sort of required well for the
distribution free pack you sort of have
a way of I mean you're doing that
against all distributions as well but
the thing is yeah you you can kind of do
enough of a sample so that it looks
uniform enough for you to go through and
prove your hardness result so yeah you
there's a reason you wanted for hardness
without it's enough that you know you
proved it just against uniform
distribution but yes you you need a
distribution that can be efficiently
sampled otherwise you won't be able to
like create the stuff that you need
okay so before hosting us here I hope
you all had a good time they had some
very interesting discussions and you
hope you enjoy an interesting
understanding of all the prospects and
challenges and come back to Simon's they
have all works this semester and the
absol I think I've seen
[Applause]